we're joined now by senator amy
klobuchar of minnesota
she is the top democrat on the senate
rules committee and a member of the
judiciary committee senator good morning
uh yesterday you must have had gone
through a terrifying day yesterday i can
only imagine what it was like can you
describe uh
what you saw as events unfolded on the
floor
you know when i hear that i was not
thinking
of how it was terrifying for myself not
once
i think it's terrifying for our country
and for our democracy that
we have a president who doesn't have
much longer
in office but a president who literally
incited this who'd been inciting it
for months and he basically sent his
supporters
down the mall and they marched right
into that capital
and i was one of the leaders in leading
the debate i had just finished an
argument asking people our members to
reject what senator cruz was trying to
do
which was to claim fraud with regard to
the state of arizona
i think one or two other people spoke
and then we were told there was a breach
in the capitol
and we were taken to another room and we
spent the afternoon
together which was by the way i think a
good thing
watching this on tv because in the end
democracy prevailed and we won i think
93
senators uh rejected this guruless
argument that they've been fraud in the
election so were you only aware of what
was happening within the capitol by
watching it on television
pretty much i was of course in contact
with my staff
um and mostly our goal my goal was to
get back to where we were knowing that
people
i mean there were literally protesters
had taken over the diocese in the senate
uh people were rummaging through desks
but we wanted to get back in there why
we were very aware uh that as you point
out it wasn't since
1814 i think tony just suggested uh that
our capital
had been taken over like this that time
by a foreign
uh a foreign force and we had to get
back in there to show the american
people that as horrific as this was
that the government was still
functioning and we were going to finish
our work
and that we were going to get those
votes counted and make very
clear that joe biden was going to be the
next president of the united states
i know senator klobuchar is as jarring
as it was it was very
i have to say gratifying to see you all
come back in
and you made the final declaration that
joe biden was in fact
going to be president as we all knew uh
for quite some time now
it was great to see it at 3 39. but yeah
i was there no i was watching you i was
watching you
but now there is discussion among uh
president trump's cabinet of invoking
the 25th amendment
i'm wondering your thoughts on that do
you think that's necessary and would you
support it
um well first of all make clear i
supported impeaching this president
uh because of his violation what i
believe has been
a violation of the law uh many many
times uh
including with what he just did now
the 25th amendment doesn't as much
involve me
could eventually but it involves his own
cabinet you'd have to have
a majority of the cabinet vice president
adjoining in
uh to remove him and that is going to be
up to them
and i think so much of this depends i
know it involves them but would you
support that are you someone that would
say now is the
time i was making clear gail i supported
impeaching him removing him from office
and i'm just being realistic about
what's going to happen here but they had
better be ready to do that
if this continues because you cannot
have a president
basically leading an insurrection
against our
own country's government do you think
that maybe for the first time senator
klobuchar that maybe even
his staunchest allies have said enough
even senator graham i wonder if you had
a chance to talk to him said
count me out enough is enough uh joe
biden said yesterday
step up mr president and condemn this
america stand up do you think that
finally maybe this is a tipping point
that something
will be done with president trump
i think it is a tipping point for these
people that have stood by him for
way too long allowed him to go after
people divide people
and they were finally last night when i
think they
saw the fruits of everything they had
done
and all of the enabling literally
invading
the temple of our democracy desecrating
it
right in front of their eyes and that
seemed to have flipped a
switch so what does that lead to gail i
don't know because we only have
a few weeks here literally less than
that before joe
and kamala are another 13 days 13 days
and
my question is are you myself
we've got we've got an inauguration in
13 days the president is still in the
white house
he's still saying the election was
rigged are you concerned about security
in washington and are you concerned
about security at the inauguration
you're part of the inaugural planning
the inauguration
of course i am but i also know that
what happened there was clearly a breach
of planning
which led to a breach of security
there's going to have to be
major major reviews of what happened and
changes made the inauguration i would
very much hope major changes there in
terms of beefing up security
i will say that is an event that they
are used to having major security at
national guard at all kinds of
security measures that have been taken
every four years
time and time again um so they must be
prepared for that
but what was going on here is they had
yes an event that usually goes along
with little
historical uh no doing no fanfare the
counting of these ballots but they knew
on social media yes that the president
had been whipping people up they knew
that
senator a lot of people asking a lot of
questions today that are in need of some
answers we thank you very much
it was good to see you conducting the
people's business early this morning
thank you
thank you for that thank you